I mean went for a rebound  basketball playing for the steel  basketball play referee loves Wilson  called the foul I stopped playing my  arm's still stuck in here and he tries  to break it  and then I get I'm the only one to get  the text so okay I mean everybody saw it  I don't have to keep talking about it if  I did that I'd probably eject this  suspended three games four games fines  but the fact that I was the only one  that got  I guess something out of that is kind of  Beyond me especially defending dpoy and  that's how he gets treated it's tough  but like I said it's maturity you know I  could have cracked his head open but I  didn't and that's the maturity we had  you know what I'm saying so we move on  from it it is what it is and control